hi I'm Norman Reedus and I'm doing the
wired I don't complete interview it
should just be Ken Norman Reedus yeah
how was Norman Reedus discovered that's
an interesting story I was working at a
motorcycle shop in Venice California had
followed a girl that I had met in Tokyo
who lived in New York and she asked me
to move to Los Angeles and at that time
I was actually in Spain and I was living
in this tiny little thing and doing
these little paintings and she said what
are you doing I said I'm doing this want
to come to LA I got a job at a
motorcycle place in Venice California
got in a fight with the guy who owned it
ended up that night going to a party up
in the Hollywood Hills drinking way too
much started yelling at a crowd of
people and then someone asked me to be
in a play and they told me you'd be the
understudy you wouldn't even have to do
anything and we'll pay you this these
many dollars a day and you just have to
show up but you don't actually have to
go on stage and do it so I was like game
on
and the first day that you didn't show
up and I had to do it I was very lucky
there was a lady named Laura Kennedy who
was in the audience liked me started
I think it's called side pocketing or
hip pocketing or something like that and
that's when they don't sign you but they
have faith that you might do something
someday and I did some things the name
of the play was called maps for drowners
it was at the Tiffany theater on Sunset
which is no longer there he had some
stupid name like towel or tad or
something like that he was like a surfer
boys boom you know Chloe came up get
born it was what's big and he got
wrapped up and the play was about an
apartment in New York that rented the
apartments are like five different
groups of people and so they all showed
up to get the keys and there was all
these people in the house and they
everyone started bitching but then they
found out that the reason why the guy
had rented it's all these people was
because he had AIDS he had to pay for
his doctor bill and so they all sort of
started to get along after that all
right the next one how to get Norman
Reed
it's hair oh that's easy you just don't
cut it I'm on a TV show that doesn't let
me cut my hair because they own my head
but yeah but I do have friends that have
salons and things like that and they've
given this haircut to people people have
come in and said hey can we get Daryl
Dixon haircuts and so it's a thing so
there you go
how Norman Reedus restaurant is not even
proper English by the way but I do have
a restaurant I have a restaurant in
Senoia Georgia where we from walk the
walking dead called Nick and Norman's I
share it with Greg Nicotero and Robert
Kirkman and Dave Alpert and a few other
people I think we're expanding to
Savannah and it's one other place I
forget Chattanooga I believe and then
I'm also part owner and uh my friend
Luke's restaurant here in New York
called cafe cheat on which is also going
to be he has one in Cobble Hill and he
has one in Tokyo and he's about to have
one in Venice California there you go
how old is Norman Reedus today's 51 had
a birthday January 6th I'm a Capricorn
just like Jesus Christ and that's all
that Halla Norman Reedus vegan yeah I've
gone back and forth with that I'm
currently doing it again I started doing
that when I was in Georgia because where
I live is where than the country and I
started getting those ready-made meals
or not the right email but they send you
the ingredients and you make them
yourself I forgot the name of it blue
something and the vegetarian ones were
just better than the other ones and I
think they sent me one by accident which
is like three weeks worth of meals and I
did it and I liked it better and
actually felt better I felt lighter and
you know we run around in the in the
woods in Georgia and the heat and you
know you gotta get keep on your feet so
I just I enjoyed it I kept doing it
alright next one why Norman Reedus
does that mean why Norman Reedus my
dad's name was Norman when I was little
he'd passed away and
yeah there you go that's why why Norman
Reedus death stranding I did the video
game cuz Gamal del Toro originally
called me and said hey a guy named Hideo
Kojima's gonna call you just say yes and
I was like who is he cuz doesn't matter
who he is just say yes and then I met
Hideo at comic-con in San Diego he came
out back when we were gonna do a
different game and uh he showed me what
he was working on and I was just blown
away the guy's like it's super genius
and then I became friends with him
started working with him and we kept on
we kept going and so we did that
stranding which was a huge hit and we're
in talks to do other stuff so that's why
cuz it's Hideo Kojima that's why Norman
Reedus sunglasses why why not you know I
I just wear them a lot they uh I have
really sensitive eyes like bright light
I just start tearing up I always have I
was in a car crash in Berlin maybe was
it like ten years ago and I know before
that I was hit by a truck by an
18-wheeler truck and I went flying
through the window of the car and my my
eyeball popped out so they had to put me
back together and so I have a whole
titanium eye socket right here and I
have like poor screws on my nose but
ever since like bright light is really
bothers me and so I wear sunglasses all
the time next one why is Norman Reed
that's so popular that's a that's a
really good question I think because TVs
a whole thing I mean you know people
they watch you from the comfort of their
living room and you know what I walk
around with big movie stars sometimes
and I get I get hounded more than they
do and I think it's because of
television I remember a long time ago
being on a plane with the cast of
friends and I thought they were gonna
storm the airplane and flip the plane
over so I think it's just television and
that's why next one why Norman Reedus on
charmed I was on charmed way back when
Rose McGowan is a friend of mine and I
love rose and we were out to dinner one
time we had the same manager at the time
and she was like what you should be on
the show and I was like yeah she's like
you could play my boyfriend I was like
hell yeah
no I said in the next day there was like
contracts and I was like oh so this is
happening and we did it and it was a lot
of fun and and I still talk to Rose so
there you go next one why Norman Reedus
tattoos jeez these are real questions I
don't know I got a few tattoos so what
don't don't yell at me
who cares all right next one what is
Norman Reedus like in real life
he's a total in real life I don't know
what I am country I'm kind of a neat
freak believe it or not my refrigerator
has to be like perfectly organized I
have like five of those little vacuums
that are robots that clean your house
all I do is pick up after my cat really
throws up everywhere I ride motorcycles
a lot
I collect punk rock 45s yeah next one
what color are Norman Reedus his eyes
usually red but that was born with blue
eyes what is Norman Reedus his birthday
January 6 1969 I'm a Capricorn Scorpio
Rising and I think I'm a Leo moon
next one what is Norman Reedus doing now
he's doing Google ads I think right now
I am I'm shooting ride season 5 I just
flew in from New Zealand which is why
I'm so asleep right now we did that the
north side of the island and then north
part of the country then the south part
then I flew in and we're supposed to fly
next week to Italy and Greece and
Croatia but I think because of the
coronavirus we've kind of put that on
hold now they're trying to figure it out
I have an art show in Copenhagen coming
up I just did Sotheby's did I have one
in Geneva
I've one in Cologne we're thinking about
Japan I'm shooting ride getting ready to
do Walking Dead talking to Hideo about
maybe doing some death stranding stuff
and being Daddy that's what I did what
was Norman Reedus his first movie my
first movie was a mimic with Guillermo
del Toro he got me my sag card or
whatever
and then after that I did six ways to
Sunday with Debbie Arry and Isaac Hayes
and what else I can't remember all right
next we're Norman Reedus height I'm like
five ten and a half fish something like
that yeah something like that by 10 a 9
foot 10 5 11 some
where does Norman Reedus come from I was
born in Hollywood Florida and I lived
there for about three days bounced
around a lot after that dropped out of
high school moved to Tokyo ended up in
Spain where I picked up the last story
that I told where Norman Reedus original
art I have there's a there's a website
called big bald gallery there's a lady
named Laurie dolphin that that runs that
for me and does shows for me like the
art shows I was talking about that I'm
about to do and the ones I just finished
I just collaborated with Mick rock on
something and we may do a book together
there's another book of photographs
coming out and then there's a bunch of
shows coming out yeah so they're where
Norman Reedus Prada oh yeah I was in a
product campaign a long time ago
I did a movie called six ways to Sunday
on the set of that Ellen Bunner North
came and shot photographs the
photographs she took to Miuccia Prada
house Miuccia at that time was doing a
series of actors and ads like whoom
Dafoe did it while Keane did it a
Japanese actor did it John Malkovich did
it and so YouTube was like I gotta find
another actor to do this next product
campaign and Ellen goes here are some
photos I shot this kid today then I got
a call from my manager saying it's
between you and Nicolas Cage to do a
product campaign and I said what's Prada
and she said well flight they'll fly you
to Paris and give you free clothes
forever and I was like never been to
Paris and so I did that and I think more
people saw the Prada ad then six ways to
Sunday so people thought that was my jam
but you know I'm short and I can't sit
still I'd never make it modern modeling
world okay next one Ken Norman Reedus
speak Japanese chotto oh she told
waddling deskah which there's actually a
funny story
Andy Lincoln and I went
to Shanghai in Tokyo and all these
different places for a press junket
I think season 3 of walking dead we
arrived and were super asleep we there's
a whole camera crew full of people
around live television
so we're drinking our coffee trying to
wake up you know trying to wake up and I
he goes you speak a little Japanese
right I go you know tiny bit and he goes
how do I say thank you for having me in
your country and I said toilet walk doko
desu ka' and so they start the thing and
he stands up and he goes before we start
toilet wa doko desu ka' and then like 20
people are going he goes he stands where
he does it louder
totally wa doko desu ka' and then he
goes what the did I just say you
just asked where the toilet was so on
live TV
Andy Lincoln is going totally wa doko
desu ka' which is one of the highlights
of my whole professional career ken
Norman Reedus ride yeah I can write I
got 12 bikes
ken Norman - Rita Singh nope not at all
you don't want me to sing I did get on
stage with anthrax and play bass guitar
and my socks that was fun ken Norman
Reedus yell yeah I can you know alright
next one when does Norman Reedus cat
again really bad English windows Norman
Reedus cat I have a cat named I in the
dark it's a black cat
my son named did that when he was five
because it's black and we had black
floors and he could only see his eyes so
he named him I in the dark he's painting
my house but I still love him when
Norman Reedus email I'm not giving
anybody my email that's for sure but I
know how to email if that's if that's an
answer when is Norman Reedus
up in the morning in the night in the
afternoon all hours of the day I'm up as
you can tell when does Norman Reedus
Instagram not very often but I have an
Instagram it's big bald head
everything else in my life which
actually comes from a Laurie Anderson
song people ask me all the time why big
bald head
my first concert was a Laurie Anderson
concert she was a performance artist and
a musician here in New York she still is
she was married to Lou Reed my mom took
me to her first my first concert was the
Laurie Anderson concert she came out in
the glow-in-the-dark outfit with the
violin just like right right right and
then I'm on a big screen behind her her
head popped up and she was the sun's
coming up like a big bald head and I
just always remembered it it's good good
out of me and that's why everything's
big both it
when does Norman Reedus get paid not
right now that's for sure
you know it comes on a I don't know I
really don't know not often enough
Hey okay is Norman Reedus nice not
really not at all his Norman Reedus
left-handed nope he's not next one
here's Norman Reedus a good I think
actors not really there's mama Rita's in
the walking dead yeah
does Norman Reedus have snapchat no he
doesn't
does Norman Reedus have teeth nope does
Norman Reedus have underwear nope
next when there's no Marita's have uber
yeah I'm a phone I've used it what kind
of dog does Norman Reedus AB he's got a
cat he doesn't have a dog he wants it on
he doesn't have it done except on the
show he's got a dog named dog that have
a cat next one who Norman Rita's zombie
prank who hasn't Norman Reedus a zombie
prank
I got zombie pranked in Tokyo by this
nice gentleman they jumped out of the
table it's good bother me while I was
playing candy crush yeah I like him a
lot but that guy Norman Reedus Boondock
Saints yeah I was in Boondock Saints
there's always talk of a third I get
asked every day Never Say Never
[Music]
who knows next week Norman Reedus John
Connor you know what that means
oh that's the guy from the yeah yeah
I'll do that
do I get powers do I get to morph - yeah
I'll do that yeah